everyone can please take their seat
again
can everyone please take their seat
all right so i would now like to
introduce our second speaker dr arthur
hansen
now when i was reading through his uh
through the accomplishments of dr hansen
i have to admit that i was a little
intimidated one of the first questions
that came to my mind was what was he
doing at my age
well
the answer is
selling 75 000 pins with a slogan on
them that he came up with give earth a
chance
dr other hanson is an officer of the
order of canada and distinguished fellow
with the international institute for
sustainable development following his
term as president and ceo from 1991 to
98.
he has worked with a number of
organizations around the world providing
initial guidance conducting research and
advising on innovation for sustainable
development environment and economy
relationships biodiversity oceans and
international development
dr hansen has a strong interest in
linking science to public policy and
works closely with government bodies in
canada the united states and asia on
specif on specific problems related to
environmental management and mechanisms
of accountability and governance for
sustainable development
in recent years much of his professional
time has been spent working it with
china
he initiated some of the largest
environmental capacity building efforts
currently underway in indonesia
simultaneously working with the
government ngos universities and the
private sector
much of this effort has involved
establishing graduate degree programs
such as environmental law and
environmental studies
he served two terms on canada's national
roundtable on the environment and
economy and was canada's ministerial
ocean ambassador with the department of
fisheries and oceans for four years
dr hansen served for 10 years as a
member of the canadian foundation for
innovation and as a mentor in the
trudeau foundation
he has provided advice to the office of
the auditor general of canada since 1990
and has chaired various national and
international initiatives
from 1978 to 1991
he was professor and director of the
school for resource and environmental
studies at dalhousie university
dr hanson holds a phd
from the university of michigan in the
field of fisheries ecology and natural
resources and a master's degree in
zoology or fisheries from the university
of british columbia
please join me in welcoming dr arthur
hansen
thank you very much and and uh when you
were speaking earlier about how much it
should cost to come to the lecture
or whether you mortgage your house i
have known people that have mortgaged
their house's
house for the oceans um
but i just want to tell you one little
story about this teaching on the
environment at the university of
michigan which the opening session of it
was
had attracted 18 000 people to an
auditorium and we had to turn people
away but we had a special secret deal
with the president of the university
because nobody got this place for free
and i was a fundraiser for all of this
and uh
it was a big week-long event that i
won't go into details on but the funny
thing about it was one night at home i
get this phone call from a guy who i
didn't know at all he introduced himself
and he said you know i think it is he
had read our perspectives which had been
published in some books and that and and
he said i think it's outrageous that the
university wants you to char wants to
charge you five thousand dollars
for one night's use and i explained to
him all the universities said nobody but
nobody gets this for free and
you're no exception this we our group
was called an act environmental action
now
and so
we were prepared to raise the money and
he said well i really like what you're
doing i'm prepared to give you five
thousand dollars to support it but i
want you to go to the university
president and say
my name and then say
uh he would give ten thousand dollars if
the university agreed not to
to
charge charges 5000 for the uh
okay so i phoned up the head of the
university
development fund
vice president for that and he
immediately said oh he's he phoned you
yes please come and see the president
tomorrow
and so i go and the president of the
university of michigan
was a labor uh negotiator
and lawyer i guess a very nice man but
i walked into his office and i had this
kind of sheepish grin on his face i knew
before he opened his mouth that we'd won
and it turned out this is one of the
biggest benefactors to the university
and uh in fact his uh his family owned
his wife's family owned a newspaper
chain running out of chicago and
apparently her mother didn't want to
give any money away her father wanted to
give money away so instead they gave it
to the kids who gave it to good causes
like the university of michigan and
so we got our money but the funny thing
about all those pins and that and also
the uh not the spin but
those pins uh they the funny thing about
that was that the um
university put a condition that we could
charge no more than 50 cents admission
to this advanced event so between
selling the pins and the 50 cent
admissions i was the finances finances
uh chairman so every day i would go
around campus and we had this great
network of people that were selling pins
and selling tickets for the event and
and i had a suitcase which i think we
still have our little silver suitcase
it was a normal little suitcase it
wasn't too big because it was filled
with coins so every afternoon i would
try and casually walk across for fear of
getting robbed because it was fairly
close to a rough city in detroit and i'd
be trying to be casual and my arm would
be getting
harder
so but there was a lot and i just gave a
talk last night at
pearson college on the west coast to phd
students from railroad university and
these very very bright and competent
young people that go into the
baccalaureate program and have the
privilege of attending pearson college
and so i tried to give them
a talk on leaders laggards and the rest
of us and i've been thinking about that
already and what you're saying uh
jordan because in the oceans area we
deal with leaders and there's lots of
them and we deal with lots of laggards
who see the world in very narrow sorts
of ways and
we also see the rest of us who are the
people in this room it's you and me
because we can't all be experts in the
oceans and i'm not expert on all sorts
of things i go out for frequent kayak
rides and talks with a guy who's a a
physical oceanographer one of the best
in the field to live in victoria
and and uh you know he gets into
discussions with me that i have no idea
what he's talking about i tried i'm like
why you know 200 foot waves and things
like this you know that i just don't
understand because it's all mathematical
and it's all in its head so we're all
learners we're all people who want to do
good but we have to deal with some
people who really have very strong
vested interests as well and who i would
be happy to take the last fish out of
the sea if they could put it into the
money from that into their pocket
so
i'm going to i thought first of all i i
think we should give
jordan an honorary uh something
in ocean studies not necessarily ocean
sciences but ocean studies is different
and we do need psychologists and people
with human behavior understandings
to bring the message out about the
oceans it's been one of the problems
scientists don't do a very good job even
though they're very good scientists
and some of them do fortunately and then
there's people like jack cousteau and so
forth many others like that
and organizations that really try hard
many of the big foundations conservation
international a whole range of ocean
oriented bodies and so forth but it's
still not enough and it won't be enough
i think until people
who actually have a lot of interest in
oceans but
but still lack
feel they lack the means to do things
about it
and and i would include uh not the mps
in that our members of parliament
tend not to understand the oceans and
some people say to me they turn people
some people in some places in canada
turn their backs in the oceans they're
more interested in agriculture and the
things that happen on land
and and that's a strong feeling that
people have that
our parliamentarians
have not risen to the challenge even
though they've the government has signed
those things
and one of the things that
differentiates us from australia is that
the australians generally they all live
on the coast is one thing surf on it
fish from it do everything near the
water
and and they actually have the strong
political will there's politicians there
who have taken the oceans as a cause and
who are very powerful uh politicians
that's helped a lot and i'll come to
that later in the talk but i want to
start off um and i've got a lot to say
i'm going to try and sit as concisely as
i can and watch the clock so we'll have
some time for discussion
um and i want to start generally
looking at the global situation and then
i want to home in on canada because we
as canadians sitting here and and maybe
some students who are not from canada
here
this is a country where you're trying to
understand right now how we do things
and that's very very important
i think we're going to learn a lot from
other countries some of the asian
countries good and bad we'll learn
that i've worked with have some very
interesting models for fisheries
management china for example they say
they laugh at our fisheries models let
me tell you
and then the loc for example and they
say we haven't got the money or the time
to be able to
debate the finer points of the models
that you have what we do is we just stop
all fishing during the spawning season
for about two or three or four months i
forget exactly what it is in the summer
time oh
and it isn't that they're doing it
perfectly but a lot of elements of that
simple mechanism work for them maybe
sometimes we need simpler things rather
than the very involved debate that goes
on between the scientists the fisheries
scientists who tend to be all concerned
about fishing and population dynamics
people like myself that deal with
ecosystems and think about food chains
and think about habitat destruction and
so forth
and and then others who take yet another
point of view which is the fisheries
economist who say get the price right uh
individually transferable quotas and all
sorts of exotica that i think are often
useful but there is no simple answer so
i'm going to be filling in the blanks
here that
jordan has left me plenty to fill in and
and i'm going to be focusing a lot on
habitat a lot on the ecosystem because
it's my belief that in addition to
worrying about fishing you have to worry
about what's happening to where fish
live which is in the water feeding on
things that in that marvelous food chain
that was described there and and
indeed if we don't take that into
account in our decision making about
fisheries then we only know about a
quarter of what's really happening out
there
so i just want to remind us first of all
that
it's fair to say that our planet is
about water and the water is salt water
70 percent of the the earth's surface is
covered by it
we depend on it every single person in
this planet whether or not they live in
afghanistan whether they live in uh
british columbia canada or indonesia or
any of the other places
we depend on
a variety of ecological services from
the oceans i won't go into that right
now
but it's very important to recognize
that secondly it is a history book of
the earth
we look at the sediments we know
understand where we get our oxygen from
and so forth and it's complex but we can
understand that
and we also depend on that as we look
for the resources we exploit where do we
find out about
how anchovies go up and down
because of el nino and la nina from the
ocean sediments we look for the scales
of the sometimes the sanctuaries there
sometimes they're not there
and in our use
sediments and so forth well all that oil
we use is basically from uh
phytoplankton from the sea and other sea
creatures it so um we have to do
understand that it's the basis of
natural wealth and of our prosperity
half the people on the planet live close
to the ocean and that is always going to
be the case
their prosperity through trade through
fishing through all sorts of different
things
we know about it
so the oceans governs trade settlement
patterns and it we now know and
understand rather clearly it also
governs climate and therefore climate
change
but it's also the source of conflict
calamity and crises
and i don't like to talk about crises
but i have to uh and particularly in
this talk uh people say the ocean is in
crisis
uh and i think it's true uh frankly
despite all what was said at the
beginning of your talk jordan and and i
would like to think that
things are nice out there on the
environment globally they're in a
downhill
turn for sure but there's a way of
looking at crisis that i think is very
important and again i go back to some of
the experiences i spend a lot of time in
china
china doesn't like to talk about
barriers about not being able to do
things and so forth but they caution me
and say look talk about crisis yes if
you wish we understand we face crisis
for a long time we face crises
how do you turn crisis into opportunity
and that's very important chinese do
that all the time crisis to opportunity
and they actually do it often they're
able to solve their crises and they're
better off
open new opportunities i talk about what
i call c2s
crisis to sustainability how do we turn
these things into a sustainable
development pattern not easy but not
impossible and particularly when i'm
talking with an audience that includes
people of the next generation who are
going to have to solve all the messes
and problems and
open the new opportunities that come
with new technologies etc
i don't want to leave you with a message
of failure
and a message of
impossibility it has to be a message of
opportunity
a message of hope
and so forth and i think we can apply
that to the ocean so some of the
examples that i'm going to present are
things that seem to be going better now
than they were say 10 years or 20 years
ago so please keep that in mind
if it gets too gross and
just remember
i'm basically an optimist and want to
see hope for the future and hope that
the people who carry the burden forward
and the institutions that i hope
finn can become as if one of those can
make real contributions to that i'm
looking at you've been like a person
over there and some of the others that i
met earlier this afternoon um i i really
am honored that i can be here to
kick off what i hope will be a
successful effort on the part not just a
view of t students but uh
students across the country because we
need we need this kind of support and
understanding
and real action that can come out of uh
the bigger
people who carry challenges forward into
the next generation the reason i was
speaking in pearson and happy to do so
pearson college
is that i'm going further and further
down the food chain i feel that we have
to be
working in a very intelligent way and
communicating with people that are still
in high schools junior high schools and
elementary schools so that they come
into the
the university world
with an attitude
of responsibility to some extent but
understanding particularly of things
where they can make a difference in the
years ahead so those are some
preliminary points
okay so now we get into the nasty stuff
ocean health and decline you're going to
hear these things
and and there's a new index and i've
given
there's a lot of words in some of these
slides don't even try and read them all
listen to me but i'm just we're trying
to take
a videotape of this and we're going to
intersperse some of the slides so i want
a little bit more detail that's why i
put it in here and also ways that you
can find this information easier
so there's this new thing that people
have been trying for some time to get an
integrated uh overview of ocean health
and you can see it's not very good
overall in the world 60 out of 100 and
if you go on the website you can find
what each country
where it's good and not good
interestingly canada gets 70 out of 100
so
maybe we can
trumpet
success in some areas but i would say
that certainly i don't see things in
great shape right now in canada in the
same way that jordan
announced as well and so let's let's
talk about health for just a second
two quick examples
beautiful place uh broughton archipelago
brought broughton archipelago is where
alexandra morton and others
feel that the caged salmon that are
aquacultured there are carrying an
excessive parasite load that the wild
salmon coming down the pink salmon from
very remote rivers on the bc coast
are picking up the parasite load and
dying off this is a big tussle between
science and
citizen science
and and
i must say
it's not a resolved issue i'm kind of on
alexander morton's side i think on this
but in general the health of the oceans
the health of ecosystems and what it
means to us brings it back right into
economic terms now this is another big
puzzle this man who i spent a day with
several years ago took this picture is
dr peter ross who's just lost his job
because the whole group of people in
toxicology that deal with ocean
toxicological issues paid for often by
people from other countries like the
united states or
and give us data that's absolutely
essential
from monitoring different
atom mainly seals but up and down the
coast you can see where pollutants are
coming across from asia because they hit
the northern stars you can find out the
effects of drugs
and diseases that come out in their
sewage from cities like vancouver and
and then if you go down towards
the southern part of what's now called
the saily sea puget sound where they've
been building naval ships and you can
find all the heavy metal issues and so
forth so i get a feeling for things so
there was a network that he was involved
with
and they've all lost their job we don't
seem to want that information anymore so
are we getting the right kind of
information on the health of the oceans
and i would submit if if we don't have
people like peter ross
then it's quite
difficult to get that information i
should also add it's hilarious working
with him he goes out wearing a hockey
helmet because there's two ways that you
get the seals you don't really want to
be the seal the seal's going to live but
it's going to have a few scars after
he's been visited or she from
peter ross so the the one way he likes
to do it is you quietly go up in your
boat and you
uh put on your hockey helmet and then
you run like hell into the water and uh
onto the shore and grab the seal they
have to be of a certain size so they're
standardized
if you're lucky you don't bash your head
on the rocks there's slippery rocks with
lots of algae the other way which he
doesn't want to do but also works is
that uh the seals go in the water and
and then you
uh he's got a thin nylon net out set out
and the seals go into the net they're
startled and and he tries to get the uh
one or two seals and make sure that no
others are in there you get about five
minutes before the steel start
struggling and maybe would drown so but
he's a very very good scientist and it
pains me greatly he'll do fine whether
that network can continue its work
properly
is beyond me i don't see how it can
health is also about people and
communities
if you live on the west coast or on the
east coast this is a prime thing that
people feel the loss they feel the loss
of livelihood the loss of
integrity of work that they've felt
important over the years as fishermen or
various other ocean related
activities and whether it's in prince
rupert in northern british columbia or
whether it's
in communities in the south shore of
newfoundland or nova scotia
this is a very serious
issue
and it's one that we don't seem to do as
good a job in canada as places like
norway
and maybe australia in in handling
and we can come back to that point
a new line new livelihoods emerge
lunenburg
school of sailing school with a
beautiful schooner
sea kayaking summer thing whale watching
and interestingly if you're into music
folk festivals and the
the folk festival part of it's held
right on the uh on the seashore and
boats come and go like this beautiful
big one in the background in the lower
picture
but there's also calamity in the oceans
and calamity takes many forms
the cyclone nargis for example
in burma where over almost 140 000
people were killed by terrible maldives
the prime spokes
country for climate change
maldives basically uh disappear uh with
sea level rise in a given amount of time
and and then there's the insidious kinds
of things like ocean acidification
and i'm i won't go through this slide
but just to say that oceans and climate
change are intimately related but don't
get nearly as much attention as the
atmospheric side of things i happen to
think that on both the mitigation side
and just the general scientific
knowledge base that the oceans are
basically still largely ignored compared
to their significance
then we go on to things and this is an
area that i'm very familiar with and
this brings me to tears sometimes
there's an area of the world called the
coral triangle
indonesia
philippines parts of malaysia and parts
of papua new guinea area
and and this is the leading center for
ocean biodiversity in the world
it's a thing that drove me first to live
in indonesia was the fact that i was
working in the caribbean on something
for my master's thesis and i realized
that for every species of this little
crab that i was looking at there was six
or seven species in the coral triangle
area
if you go to that area the reefs are
being destroyed at an incredible rate
partly its stupidity it's greed
it's market demand for certain things i
could go on
fish are poisoned
so you can get maybe a tenth of them for
aquarium fish saltwater aquarium fish
that's coming under control a bit people
go off and risk their lives
to have in the last decades risk their
lives to go into old munitions dump
dumps in
west papua and papua new guinea
to to take the explosives to take them
out of the shells and then go back and
blow up reefs with them and i've seen
these reefs in some cases small islands
for example in sulawesi
where
where the the very lives of people
depend on the integrity of the reef
because they protect the small islands
around where people live
and still people will come in from
outside and blow up the reefs just to
get the fish stun the fish take the fish
goodbye go to another reef and the
damage that's rigged in that process is
is quite incredible i'll come back to
the coral triangle because the countries
now
recognize that that it's urgent that
it's a crisis situation
and they're trying their best to do a
number of things one of the
one of the important points is that they
talk about a blue carbon budget in other
words the reefs if they're properly
managed in that will extract a great
deal of
greenhouse gases as a consequence of the
reef being there and more or less do it
permanently so there's always good news
and there's lots of bad news
west africa
the fishing
the term
which i don't really like but it's
illegal
unreported
and it's unsustainable as well but
fishing
and this is one of the prime areas that
is
bringing people in from the surrounding
countries and taking fish caught uh
taking fish illegally and then these
fish will be transported off this is a
korean vessel
on the bottom
uh so it'll be transported to korea
possibly through
europe uh and some sold in the eu as
well on the bottom
it's a mothership
with illegal trawlers that are out there
and there's now spotting mechanisms
where local populations because as was
already said people now have access to
equipment like this waterproof cameras
and this that and the other access to
the internet to know exactly which ship
it is that's uh fishing and people that
go out in their canoes and take pictures
and then report that so this is one of
the interesting things that technology
can be very helpful in this process
and then finally i'm going to talk quite
a bit this evening about the arctic
changing environment and development
pressures these are some photos i wish i
had been in a nice position to be able
to take these taken by department of
fisheries and ocean staff
but narwhals and
belugas coming up in the little areas
that are open in the arctic well we know
there's going to be lots more areas open
in the future but we don't know what the
fate of these animals will be now
i did this diagram to try and understand
the overall governance of ocean use
and i know a lot about that mainly
because i've worked with some very
interesting lawyers and others
people involved with fisheries
management and ocean management and
don't worry about all the details i i i
did this diagram about the year 2000
hasn't really changed much except that
now there's not just the 1992 rio but as
was pointed out we're up to 2012 rio
plus 20.
um and the the important point here is
that um
whatever we do with the oceans now
doesn't just involve canada doesn't just
involve a province in canada it involves
international management
the use of global consensus documents
like the law of the sea
it involves trade and investment
activities of various sorts and i'm
going to talk about some of these
national and local interests which are
often very vested interests and not in
the best interest of the ocean but
sometimes they are and are not listened
to and the generation of knowledge
which comes not just as knowledge from
scientists but it comes from people that
have
a flame in their belly like
we heard in our last talk and
people that are in native communities
first nations
community groups
and many many other interests so
knowledge now is drawn from many places
how do we put that knowledge together
and so we have things like a very uh
very very good thing called the global
ocean forum i don't have time to go into
the
but i suggest you take a look at it and
this has become kind of a pressure group
at the international level
and you can see don't worry about all of
them but there's a lot of different
areas and all these areas relate back to
the fundamentals of aquatic resource
management fisheries
there's also a new
yet another i hasten to add and i don't
know what they're going to be able to do
a global ocean commission that's been
established launched just a few weeks
ago with a focus on the high seas those
areas of the deep blue that
jordan correctly pointed out are not
necessarily all the productive areas but
they do play a major role still in our
use of the oceans and one of the big
questions is what who should
how should high seas
uh marine protected areas be set up
and how should they be managed because
all those
neat things like bluefin tuna that go in
a big circle around from the gulf of
mexico up to the east coast to canada
across to west africa and then across to
here and they face a gauntlet of
fisheries boats
a tremendous number each of those fish
is worth 50 thousand dollars
one or two of those fish means the
difference for a canadian fisherman
between a good year and a bad year
and so the incentive to keep to have
sustainability of the harvest but
there's also japanese in the high seas
and there's people in the mediterranean
side et cetera and there's a lot of some
illegal fishing so anyways paul martin's
a canadian member of this and i wish him
luck but we frankly
have had lots of very good advice from
global ocean commissions and we haven't
seen the uptake of that advice nearly as
strongly as we should and that's a
troubling matter
so i'm entitled the
talk
not just for the taking
and and i really mean that the oceans
are not just there for us to take
we have to give we have to give a lot we
have to give our best to make the uses
of the ocean sustainable we have to
understand that other creatures on this
planet have
a strong rationale for being included
in the list of voters of the ocean the
people the creatures that have some take
on that uh
massive set of resources out there
so but for us we at least can talk back
and forth as humans to each other
uh and uh we have to devise what i'd
call a responsible care approach for
canada's owners
and so i'm going to go through some of
what i consider the elements of that to
be
including some of the things that
directly relate to fisheries
first question and this comes from uh
john fraser who i
think a lot of former minister of
fisheries and oceans canada who lives in
the west coast and he talks
as a person who is totally and
absolutely committed to the health and
the well-being of the oceans and says
who speaks for the oceans
and what are they doing about it and i
think that for your group finn you
should ask that question you should be
one of the groups that's speaking for
the oceans but what are you going to do
about it what is it that you can do to
make a difference and that question
should be first and foremost in your
mind
here's a couple of canadian authors to
add to the very good list uh and that
was a short list uh by the way that
jordan uh mentioned there's lots of
others but the book seasick uh written
by alanna mitchell former global male
writer she put a couple of years of her
life into writing this book and it's
very
very good
it's been highly acclaimed in fact
and it's based on science but she's not
a scientist be the first to say that
she's a journalist trying to explain
things about the oceans and you can see
from her title what her
conclusion is
farley moet who's often a controversial
figure but his book sea of slaughter
will go into more detail about the
things that jordan was talking about
about this unending slaughter of
creatures from the ocean over the last
500 years in canada
i once showed a film about sea of
slaughter at dalhousie university and
the graduate students that
asked me to stop it in the middle and
they said we can't take any more
if this is what the situation is why are
you spending your time on this why don't
you just give up and try and do
something simpler
well that's not the way i'm constructed
i guess but but the point is uh it's not
pleasant reading but it's a reality
check about what we have done in the
past
and i'd also like to pay tribute to some
people who
you know canada as a nation has produced
some of the best fisheries and ocean
scientists in the world
at one point in time we were probably
with along with a few uh european
countries
having the best scientific journals and
so forth and
paying the most attention in terms of
free access to information and
and good research uh codes of ethics and
funding
in in the ocean sciences
and and uh i've only put three names up
here of people who are involved in ocean
studies or ocean science uh people that
have regrettably passed away i'd
if they were still alive and there's
many many of my colleagues that i could
put up here i'd be hard
pressed to choose which ones
but let me just give you this very brief
profile of these people
rand myers ransom myers
worked for the government and left the
government wanted to be more independent
became a leading
professor at
delhauser university
and it got a great following from the
world's press
because he told it like it was
using his accurate scientific approaches
as best he could
about the state of fisheries in various
parts of the world and including
those on the east coast of canada
elizabeth man borgesa who
many people worship around the world
she's the daughter of thomas mann the
great author and a wonderful person who
gave herself over completely to the
oceans also at dalhazi university but
headed the international oceans
institute and trained and got the money
to train by hounding people like pierre
trudeau and others in canada saying
please give me money and then using that
money to get more money and so thousands
of people now have been trained in
understanding the complexities of oceans
because of her work she was also a great
author
on the oceans as well and the third
person who died recently and who i had
the good fortune to work with was a
psychologist so not all is lost for you
in this field
he sorted out how to
reduce the damage from the interaction
between fishermen and whales
in in
newfoundland
that was his first claim to fame many
more things since then but he learned
how using basic behavioral
things that involved both the behavior
of the whales and the behavior of the
fishermen so that when whales got which
was very frequent which when whales got
caught in the fisherman's traps for cod
traps
they
and these are big whales really big
whales and and everybody got upset the
whales got upset enough and died
fishermen
put themselves in danger but lost a
great deal of money and who wants to
kill a whale so anyways he worked that
out and had teams that could actually go
out and do it so
but he did many more things
and and these are people who made a
substantial contribution in their
lifetimes and
serve as an inspiration for me and for
many others
um getting down and again i'm just
suggesting maybe if you're serious about
wanting to understand what we should be
asking as research questions here's what
some of the leading nation scientists in
canada
are
talking about and they they bring they
bring in these four areas
yes break improve the fundamental
scientific understanding but we've got
to have the information about monitoring
and how you use that information and you
have to look at really understanding the
impacts of human activities and then
you've got to bring this information
back into governance and management so
it isn't just about managing a specific
fish stock
we've gone beyond that now because when
you try and do it we find often it's
almost impossible because there's big
questions that that are ignored
in that approach
this is a rather interesting new uh
document that's just come out but
it gets to the what i'm going to try and
say in uh some of the things tonight
then there's other people that so
there's this the scientific community
speaks relationship then there's all
these folks
cpaws canadian parks and wilderness
society the vancouver aquarium is a
great place
ecology action center in nova scotia the
living ocean society in the west coast
wwf they have major programs that relate
back to this and and i would really
really uh strongly underline
first nations and all three coasts of
canada four coasts if we include the
maritimes uh we include the great lakes
uh they have an incredibly important
role because they have constitutional
rights
that relate back to the oceans
so we have this opportunity we've got
the longest coastline in the world
and our maritime estate people don't
often recognize is about
depending on how you count it uh
but it could be as high as 70 percent of
the land area
so
that's that's an important figure to
remember and then we have this uh
purple exclusive economic zone which
from 1977 onwards has been the
opportunity side for canada it's been
perceived as if we only had our hands on
the management of that now we haven't
had it for
since 1977 we could do much better get
much more value from our use of the
ocean we could make it much more
sustainable reality has sometimes been a
little different now if you'll allow me
a little bit of
west coast snobbiness
from coast to coast to coast to coast so
we start in vancouver but the one i like
here is just near my home in oak bay
victoria
boxing day
and you think of boxing day sales while
the people in
in
oak bay think of sailing in a different
sort of way on boxing day and there they
are out in the water in their wetsuits
and their boats with mount baker in the
background but
here's another amazing thing the western
arctic
um
that ice highway
goes 40 kilometers it comes up from the
new vik
you travel all along the mackenzie river
and then you go to the little hamlet of
tuktoyaktuk which is important
strategically for a number of reasons
and the last 40 kilometers you're
actually traveling on the arctic ocean
the frozen ocean so they've just
announced this week that
they are going to put in an all-season
road
which will be 300 million dollars and of
course one of the reasons for that is
simply that they won't be able to use
ice highways up there much longer as
becomes the season becomes too short and
tenuous
and this is one of a person i did a lot
of mentoring with
janelle
kennedy
on the eastern arctic where of course
this is a
prime area for what's going to happen in
the future with icebergs and so forth
but also one of the most interesting
areas
because
we don't know very much about the
continental shelf in that area some
people say it's better known on the uh
say surface of the moon than it is
along the bottom of that area
people are already looking at it though
for oil and gas exploitation
for shipping purposes
and they're also looking for
fisheries
surprising how many things are happening
in the arctic right now where people
want to go up and test fish on the east
coast it's for things like cod the west
coast there's already salmon moving
around into all the
pacific salmon are now found in in some
arctic rivers
to the other coast
gander and i was in a small airplane
with john lean the person the whale man
gander and fogo island
all covered in ice at that point
and then to a place where
i really enjoy being which is lunenburg
nova scotia one of the great shipping
wooden ship building and so forth
places and happened to be there the day
they were relaunching the lunos 2
almost
newly built
and it's kind of interesting if you look
along that shoreline there's the sea
shepherd you would know the shepherd
paul watson's boat which has been
impounded by canada
for
reasons that i won't explain right now
and then you can see these other large
boats
and you can see the dartmouth ferry and
a small naval vessel in dry dock there
as well it really is an active little
spot but don't forget that the ocean's
influence extends to
ontario not only directly through the uh
region
and particularly there for quebec but
also the water comes out of ontario the
quality of the water and so forth
creatures from the ocean come up into
the
great lakes
including those ill wives and
some other little things that are really
nasty and cost us billions of dollars in
management of
these species
but
it's also
officially considered in canada that
these are inland seas that deserve to
fall under the
purview of fisheries and oceans for some
things
and then we think of the gulf of st
lawrence now
it's a very interesting body of water
there but what i'd like you to look at
is those little circles and then i'm
going to show you some more circles
um one of the most interesting things
for me of trying to simplify my
understanding a very complex
oceanography is to look at the things
that go round and round in gyres and
circles of one sort of another the
simple example is when you go see
kayaking and you're out there straining
against the current and so forth maybe
the tides against you and there's a
strong current maybe a wind blowing
against it
so you go into shore
and then you find a counter current and
then you're just swept along because
that counter current is going this way
while the main current's going that way
so you get a free ride instead of being
out it
so lots of other things get free rides
so if you look at what's called the
haida eddie here you see these little
swirls out in the uh
going out into the ocean there
well they're driven by the fresh water
which is all that red stuff coming down
from the rivers like the skina river and
some others
and and
those swirls are are driven by the
current patterns of the ocean
and they go out and they transport all
the larvae from the inshore and the
nutrients out to the offshore so
you talked uh
jordan about the the sea mounds
and one of these now boy seamoth is just
out there up near the top end of it uh
that second set of swirls up there and
and uh
that's how it gets all the fish
that
that are out there that make it very
special and why it's a high productivity
area another one is in the beaufort gyre
up in the arctic and that's a collection
point for the whales
in the arctic and some of the fish
species as well because of the high
productivity
same in the gulf stream and here's a
good example of how little we understand
for a long time the oceanographers
didn't understand that there were these
gyres in in that area of the uh gulf
stream so the gulf stream is going off
coming up the coast of the united states
and heading off to europe then there's
all these counter currents that are
swirling around just like the ones i'd
be looking for on a kayak and they're
warm water they're bringing warm water
in off the ocean so
if these
counter currents happen to be in place
just at the time that the scallops which
are down on
georgia's bank shelf are spawning
then the little creatures coming up get
swept away by the warm water because
they're cold water creatures
and and you don't get a good spawn that
year so if you're going to try and
understand the management of things you
have to understand phenomena like the
the gyres and the eddies and the oceans
and and this is uh
my first introduction here of things
ecological physical ecological phenomena
that that won't come out through an
examination of studying fishing pressure
because they're environmental and focus
and there's lots of those kinds of
things in the oceans
so this has led to great tests you can't
believe it's just like among economists
they you know what's the saying that if
you get three economists in the room
you'll get four opinions you know or
something like that and well the same is
true with fisheries biologists i've
actually
sat in the office of an ecological
uh
ocean scientist
in british columbia i just happened to
be there when he was
this is after the cod disaster and he
had just published an article with some
others
in science magazine very highly
respected journal
saying that the fisheries
management people basically didn't
understand what they were doing
which i agreed with him by the way and
we were talking about that the phone
rings just at that moment from a fishery
scientist who i won't give the name of
in eastern canada but who worked for
government and who was threatening to
sue him for defamation of character
because they had they were at odds
they were
analyzing the same problem
from entirely different points of view
and particularly when i lived in nova
scotia i could give you endless stories
of this and
and they they were
in one case there was a whole very large
ecosystem group and they were shut down
they were shut down by
the higher ups because they were
producing data that were at odds with
what the population dynamics people were
producing i'm giving a simplified
version of things but so the point is um
and i used to say this to students when
i was teaching uh fisheries things in
in nova scotia
don't trust the experts you know form
your own opinions
the experts are often very wrong and
they wear blinders just like everybody
else in society and one of the biggest
ones is about fisheries management
same could be said at times in the past
for forest management but fisheries
management is inherently even more
complex at least trees stand
in line and can be counted
rarely is that the case with fish
because of water currents among other
things so here's here's just a little
collection of books and i could
triple that collection about these
different points of view and i won't go
into details now this is a sad story
here
this is in lunenburg nova scotia and how
many have ever been to lunenburg how
many have ever been to nova scotia
great great well if you go down to
lunenburg you'll see this very moving
very very moving
set of
what would you call these obelisks maybe
i guess
and and they list
as much as possible the names of people
who were killed at sea in some cases
there might be they don't have all the
names because it would be 50 or 100
people were killed in 1927 and again
while we were living there there was a
terrible incident but these are just
people from lunenburg area because this
was the grand bank's fisheries
and
um and it's very moving to see it but
the point is
uh we remember a lot about our ocean
past and we even tend to glorify it uh
or feel sad about it or whatever but
what have we actually learned you know
and there's
just a little window dressing there is a
couple of postage stamps to remind us
about the glorious past and
that's the
fellow on the right uh
angus walters was a very famous captain
of the fastest of the of the ships the
bluno's
newfoundland that's that abundant cod
population
but the interesting thing is the man
that told us early on
stuff that is still being quoted
is harold innis from the university of
toronto
who was an economist who dealt with this
idea of heartland and hinterland in in
canada and the fact is that we were
heroes of wood drawers of water
fur traders but also
we dipped into the ocean and
he wrote
this what happens when you
get a really truly abundant
resource like the cod fisheries that's a
that's his book
written in 1940
very prescient
and basically he's saying as
an abundant tradable resource
can fuel an economy but it also traps
you in many ways and and that is what
has happened in canada in a sense we've
we've relied on super abundant natural
resources not just fish but but it
allows us i've thought a lot about this
over the years trying to understand why
we behave towards the resources we do
like for example with a cod when we
lived in nova scotia you know we'd go in
and buy this fish that was awful
in the stores you couldn't get good
caught in the stores
and the reason it wasn't good was
because it was mishandled right from the
time it was it wasn't iced it wasn't
bled so you'd have a nice open flesh
and
it was treated as if it was going after
the carols uh to be treated as salted
cod you know low value commodity
uh some other people icelanders
norwegians and some others didn't do
that they treated the fish property they
got a very good value added and they
started respecting the resource base
even more so that's the important thing
for
those with an economic ben to recognize
is that you can one of the one of the
ways in which we can actually get more
out of our resource is to add value to
it handle it carefully respect each fish
that we catch which gets again into why
is it that we can go in and use trawlers
and you know take a small fraction of
the fish but anyways a lot of the stuff
goes back to harold innis and now the
other thing is and i hear i differ a bit
from what uh
what was said about the empty oceans yes
the oceans are empty because we've we've
knocked out a lot of the food chain but
there still can be an abundance and as
you correctly pointed out uh jordan if
you like eating uh jellyfish which uh
actually i do there
and i keep asking my chinese colleagues
well why is it that you eat uh
you know chicken feet or certain other
things with some of those certain other
things well it doesn't for the taste
particularly it's for the crunch the
crunch feather
and jellyfish is one of those things
and the same with indonesians and others
they like the crunch and they're
delicious now they're dried in
newfoundland newfoundland couldn't
believe it's good luck when they
discovered that there were actually
people in the world that wanted to eat
jellyfish but
they so they started drying them and
exporting them into these little flat
patties you know but and there's certain
other things that i could mention as
well and squid uh of course is one of
them and so what you find is an ocean
that gets
very abundant in those creatures that
can be low in the food chain often in
what we call detritus food chains you
know the stuff that rains down into the
water column so
lots of fishermen are now happy to see
no cod and nova and uh well i don't know
about nova scotia so much but
certainly whoops everything shut off for
me i guess
have you got it there still yeah yeah
can i have some technical help up here
like i've got nothing on my screen and i
do like seeing the screen
oh okay okay
okay and then how do i get it to go back
here just
okay so so we now have very very
valuable snow crab and northern shrimp
and basically the ecosystem has changed
don't expect the cod to come back
unless something catastrophic happens to
these guys because these have replaced
basically replaced the cod
we'll see kind for sure we'll see some
other ground fish but we probably won't
see them in the abundance because these
guys are eating in the food chain now
so but that's not necessarily a bad
thing
you know that there's fewer cod if you
ask the fishermen a lot of them that
have made a lot of money off these new
species will say hey we're making more
money we've got better bullets etc the
question is and i've tried to look at
this question with some people in the
auditor general's office
some years ago and we concluded that
there was no knowledge base to support
the hypothesis that these actually were
being sustainably harvested the new ones
in other words we might end up with the
same problem
but let's go back again to what another
thing that was mentioned earlier and
that is electronic gear and so forth
well it's it's not exactly new but it's
in this period from about 1970 on um and
this man got a an honorary doctorate
from i think the university of um new
brunswick
and this oddly enough
was one of his boats uh uh which i
happen to see in the dry dock in
lunenburg
um and and uh captain medford matthews
was a real innovator with gear and he
brought in so this wasn't the first
trawler that came by any means into the
region but it's it's kind of like the
early brand of the
of the trawlers that are of a modern
type and well-equipped with all the gear
that can take a lot of fish sonar things
and other equipment well here's what
they look like now uh here's another one
with a couple of kayakers for scale
and and these things are essentially the
bulldozers of the sea
they they they do so much damage to the
bottom
uh they rip things up and i think
eventually
probably we'll see these things phased
out for other types of gear that's my
hypothesis
but in the interim these are deadly
machines for from the point of view of
what they can haul for fish it doesn't
mean that they
can't be made to be
useful contributors towards
sustainability if they're held in check
but
particularly when you get in
these big vessels and then you get
facilities on them or
factory boats that can accompany them
that can take
an immense amount and stay at sea for
long periods of time because they can
devastate
a whole region of the ocean very quickly
now then we move to what happens to fish
after it gets caught
if you look at this
plant at the top
national seafoods
is the world's
one of the world's major fishing
companies
and one of the largest ones in canada
this plant located in lunenburg was the
world's largest fish plant in the 1980s
now my daughter laura will quite well
remember when we used to go down to the
cottage some days we were down wind of
this
this boat this
plant and it was just a bad smell they
were taking all the remains and make
cooking it to make it into fish meal and
selling it
but what does national seafood do now
white fleshed fish such as cod haddock
and pollock and a bunch of others are
kind of what
some people in the banking business
would call fungible i.e they're all you
can exchange them interchangeably
they're white flesh you can make them
into fish and chips you can even take
something like tilapia
which is a fresh water fish and call it
cod
and that happens sometimes illegally but
it happens
so in today's market supply chain
because china has become the most
efficient processor they get all this
fish going to china it goes through big
ports like rotterdam where it gets all
muddled up it could come from west
africa it could come from south america
whatever
gets turned into
chunks of fish
that are partially processed there
then it comes back to companies like the
one in lunenburg
where people
squirt some nice things on top of it and
maybe make it a little fancier make it
into a frozen dinner or something like
that then it gets stamped made in canada
and then sent to the united states or
consumed in canada or maybe in europe
even
so that's that's a reality so if you
were listening to the radio in the last
few weeks there's been a release of a
report that estimates that something
like 30 percent of this fish is actually
mislabeled
because once it gets to rotterdam or
wherever you don't know whether it's a
cod or what whatever it happens to be so
market supply chains go through this
complex thing
and um
it makes it very difficult for us to
know a whether we're really eating what
we think is caught or whatever else it
might be
b
whether it was caught sustainably
or even whether it went through some
mishap and it's
in its process
that lowered the quality of the fish so
this has become a major major problem uh
in in
ocean management and in management of
the seafood chains the sort of thing
that you're talking about if you want to
be a good citizen and only eat
sustainably produced fish
fortunately there are solutions
um but just to give you an another
example of this
and this is an area
where
australia was furious with us see these
this large fish the patagonian tooth
fish which some of you may have eaten us
how many people and i shouldn't ask the
question but if you want to raise your
hand
have you ever eaten chilean sea bass
okay well chilean sea bass is one of
those fancy names that's given for
something that's actually a fish coming
from antarctica
and for the most part unsustainably
produced and at one point in time this
has been cleaned up quite a bit now but
it was going from
antarctica
on pretty much an unregulated fishery
even though the australians were really
making a pitch for it and and then it
would go to china
it would be handled there then it would
come to canada and then it would be
transshipped to the united states as
canadian fish
australians weren't very happy about
that i can tell you uh but but again
this just illustrates things so one of
the ways to get around this is through
all these various uh choices that you
can make and people that help you to
make good choices it started with the
monterey bay aquarium and now the
vancouver aquarium is in there seafood
watch
the most critical thing is something
started by wwf and some others in the
private sector
on what's called the marine stewardship
council which is now certifying some
some species of fish and interestingly
many chefs now in the world will refuse
even in countries in places like hong
kong and some of the big hotels they
will refuse to handle fish that are not
certified
and this is a real step forward and
i could tell you some interesting
stories but i better move on so just go
to fishchoice.com and take a look at
some of the things that are on there or
any of these individual websites
this is the future this is a future that
responsible seafood companies like
nationals see
see is what they would be faced with
always and countries like china are now
starting to recognize that they will
have to become involved then there's
some of the really nasty things like uh
sharks finn i took this picture in a
chinese restaurant but
the interesting thing there is um
yumming the guy who's
so tall that he reaches to this guy a
basketball player from china respected
highly respected within china and a
person who doesn't just play basketball
but he's very interested in public
policy issues and
and he came out and said i will not have
my wife to be and i will not have
shark fin soup
served as is traditionally done at
chinese weddings
and i'm going to encourage all my fellow
basketball players and sports figures
and so forth to do the same he's
probably had more impact than any other
single thing of uh the scientists and
others who
ring their hands because china is the
primary place now for shark fin soup and
where all those 70 million or more shark
fins are going
now
little known facts
i think they're facts
but it's always interested me in nova
scotia that there's been a sword fishery
and if you go back far enough there was
there was all sorts of books written by
people i think zane grey type of books
very rich people used to go to nova
scotia and and catch them off
as a sport fishery but
in the 1940s still even there was a
harpoon sword fishery in glace bay up in
cape breton island hundreds and hundreds
of boats this is just one picture from
the
from the
era and they had these canoes that they
went out in and men would go out there
with harpoon waiting to catch a 400 or
more pound swordfish
the interesting point about it is it
still exists
and one of the points right now is that
the marine stewardship council has been
asked to certify harpoon fisheries in
the united states and in canada
and then also the pelagic long line now
you got introduced to the long line and
and some people wrap their hands to put
their hands to their heart and say the
long line is the way to go because it's
not involving those trawlers but what
the long line does is catches turtles
sharks and all sorts of other things
that are not the wanted species
at the same time as they're catching
swordfish
but
controversially uh the marine
stewardship council has awarded the
northwest atlantic canadians
sword fishery which amounts to about 10
million dollars a year
um
certification that they were doing it
properly i'm not so sure i don't know
on this one but the interesting thing is
they had already awarded
the
spear fishery
for the
sorry the yes the spear fishery for the
sword fishery uh they're still using
spears out there and if you go if you
google
something along those lines you can
actually see little things for sportsmen
in the united states for example going
out on boats and
throwing their harpoons
at uh getting swordfish
but you can see what happens and
that the government in the late 90s
really put a clamp on things because you
could see the decline on the
on the swordfish going down there and
went below what is considered a maximum
sustainable yield of biomass and and you
can see as a consequence of stopping
that fishery how it's built up to the
point now where they feel that they can
reinstitute a limited sword fishery so
these are the sorts of things this is an
oddball little example it's not one of
the great fisheries but there's dozens
even hundreds of these other kinds of
fisheries out there that don't get the
same kind of press as they caught
fishery
the big ones
the biggest single thing we have going
for us now is the lobster and then
haddock
is a ground fish that is still retaining
some place in the
in the scale of things a very nice fish
to eat but these are the things that
sustain the small communities in the
south shore of nova scotia bay of fundy
and so forth but the point here is that
the haddock went down
and
it went down maybe because of
overfishing but it wasn't on the scale
of overfishing of the
of the cod almost certainly water
temperature has played a role in it so
again what's cause and effect between
fishing pressure
and uh fish abundance sometimes not very
clear here's another one this just a
friend of mine took this picture last
weekend or weekend before
one day fishery and you get all these
collections of boats going out and and
they kill immensely uh they take huge
schools of herring and then the gulls
and other birds are their eagles etc and
the point here though is that the
abundance of herring
is at the greatest level in the last 30
to 40 years
responsible fisheries scientists would
say we have no idea why
they may claim credit too and say oh
it's because of our careful management
but it's been up and down and up and
down there's i don't have time there's
an awful lot of interesting stories
about this fishery and about the way the
native people the first nations along
the coast perceive how it should be
managed where they wouldn't have any of
these boats out there they would be
because it's mainly managed for a
herring road you know the eggs and and
they go to japan and places like that
but um
they would manage by
lifting the things out on off kelp where
they've been spawned
by the fish themselves and get rid of
the boats period
so there's differing points of view of
what you can do and some of those things
i think are going to be the things for
the future salmon
i have spent a lot of my life looking at
reading about trying to understand
salmon i'll be the first to say it's
really difficult
not the only person to say that
there's aboriginal interests which are
strongly constitutionally supported
commercial interests which often are on
the decline sports fisheries interests
which claim to produce about
5 to 16 times the value for fish landed
because fishermen spend a lot of money
and then there's aquaculture and
anybody anybody here from bc
great well you know that this is not
exactly an easy subject in british
columbia i mean everybody has an opinion
on it and and it's really difficult but
look at this
this is a plot uh several years ago of
watersheds encountered because you have
to involve the fresh water watersheds in
british columbia i should say were sakai
salmons in decline so the yellow and red
watersheds huge number of watersheds
under threat that's likely to increase
because of global warming and the
streams are warming up and other things
happening in the watersheds the pine
bark beetle killing all the trees trees
go
water runs off isn't there for the
spawning season so the salmon is truly
in trouble no matter what
aquaculture if you look at a net like
this this is a fairly well-run
aquaculture
setting in guatino-san each of those
netted areas holds about fifty thousand
fish this size and if you've ever seen
anything like that close up it's quite
amazing so this is just fish packed
in place the fish aren't discontented
and
there's varying points of view about it
but some of you may know that
our prime minister appointed a justice
from british columbia it was called the
cohen commission uh to look at the
future of the phrase of riverside and
the biggest run
and and
don't read all of this but the basic
point is that uh
cohen said if if people were expecting
that i'd find a smoking gun one
causality to it no
no way and and i think i certainly felt
that would be what he would come up with
at the end but there's all sorts of
factors but read what he says fraser
river sockeye face an uncertain future
shrinking resources
which may result in delays in
implementing reforms in research
shrinking resources being
less money around dfo has been cut badly
um meaning that the stressors to which
sakai are exposed will continue and the
deterioration of sockeye habitat will
get worse the waters constituting fraser
river sockeye habitat are warming
and then pointing out
that basically uh because the government
had taken a bunch of amendments before
receiving his uh to the fisheries act
that uh in fact the future of management
of the fraser river is unknown and
that's putting it in the most positive
terms
and and so
these are guarded comments the whole
report the summary of that if you want
to get a sense of that particular very
important resource and why it's
difficult to manage read that report
so
my my concern see we have these various
things that we can do in canada for the
oceans and two big things one is the
fisheries act which is in a is in a very
old one of the first pieces of
legislation we had in canada and i won't
give you a boring and dull description
of all the parts of it but it sets the
basis for conservation of fish for
pollution control and a number of other
things related to habitat etc and also
sovereignty over our resource and
sovereignty between the federal
government and provincial governments in
its management
it's a very important piece of
legislation it's been changed quite
dramatically in the last year
placing less emphasis on the habitat
aspect in particular
but we also have the oceans act in
canada and this was a new piece of
legislation that came out in the 1990s
and and essentially set a new basis of
management around ecosystems sustainable
development in other words balancing
between the various kinds of uses of the
ocean and specified the need for uh
attention to marine protected areas and
also
what was called law eventually became
called lomas large ocean management
areas to take big chunks of the ocean
and try and develop
plans for them i'm just going to give
you a very brief overview of a few of
these and you can
this talk will be available to anybody
that wants it and you can see in more
detail but but the lomas represent
a move towards the ecosystem-based
approach
and and one that's based on consultation
among the various users whether they're
first nations whether they're oil and
gas
fisheries and so forth it's building
relationships and dialogue among the
various users and the idea is to plan
for surprises
plan for
management strategies that you could
actually implement
and get that information in advance of
development
so
one that i'm very familiar with is isom
east coast
scotian shelf
and they produce good work
and so forth i won't talk about it
anymore one that's citizen led
scientists led and led by both canada
and the united states is the area of the
gulf of maine particularly georgia's
bank is part of that and then up into
the bay of fundy and here the federal
government has a limit it has taken a
limited role
um
and
it's been the states and the provinces
working together that's really done some
very innovative work won't have time to
go into it but i wanted to say just one
thing if you this is the boundary line
between the two countries uh
painfully worked out and i could tell
you interesting stories about that
because i was had some role in some of
that it was very interesting but uh if
you look up towards the bay of fundy and
into towards new brunswick which is
just
to the right of the top of the line of
the top line
whales
and ships collide up there because
that's where it's a natural one of these
areas with lots of currents flowing and
gyres and so forth and and it's
incredibly productive the whales come up
there to feed in the summer some of the
scarce as well humpbacks are there but
some of the other whales and and they
collide with the ships so you get these
ships going up into
particularly for an oil refinery located
up there and they find a whale draped
over this they have a kind of a bulbous
front on them and there's a whale dead
whale there and and so the right whales
particularly there's only about 300 of
them left i think and they were being
knocked off right now
no pun intended
in that area
so there was a simple solution it was a
very simple solution
and one that's worked remarkably well
they just changed the shipping lanes
slightly and they put in place a kind of
a spotting mechanism because you can see
the whales and so people would know
where the whales tended to be clustered
on a given day so there's some leeway in
where the ships go
and problem not completely solved but
let's say 80 solved so this there's
there really are win-win situations out
there and the charge for that
was led by you can see how nova scotia
goes down to kind of a little point not
the big part of nova scotia but there's
a little kind of peninsula a beautiful
place
the school teacher was living out there
and she took it upon herself to be part
of the solution
and organized local groups to actually
spot and be able to say where the whales
would be and demonstrate it to the
scientists who didn't really believe in
this i don't think very strongly that
that it could actually be a solution
so it started from a citizen and i have
a lot of respect for what i see as
citizen science in the oceans throughout
this country i could give you many other
examples in the west coast and the
arctic and so forth
another one that i think involves a
heavy degree of citizen input is the
same gulf of st lawrence
action plan which is being implemented
primarily through
environment canada and here there's
something called zip we don't need to go
into the details of it but zip
committees exist throughout the gulf and
around particularly around
quebec it's all this is all about quebec
um and
the the neat thing about it is that uh
it brings the stakeholders together and
they come to real solutions about local
problems that affect their part of the
gulf of st lawrence and the government
and others provide a broader input into
overall what the saint lawrence action
plan would look like so there's some
degree of coherence throughout the whole
region now these are good things that
are happening and they've
they've been developed by people working
together painstakingly working together
i might add for more than a decade of
interaction overcoming all sorts of
obstacles and differing points of view
narrow points of view etc so these are
some of the good things that are
happening in canada
uh one that i helped to get underway in
terms of
some of i won't go into all sorts of
stories about it for time reasons but a
terrible name pinsema pacific north
coast integrated management area and
this includes um what i hate the word
also world class the phrase world class
but the oceans in this area
are stunning in terms of the diversity
of life
and also the intactness of the
ecosystems in this whole area uh in the
northern part of vancouver island
um up to prince rupert there's only 15
or 20 000 people living in that whole
area and that's an area that's probably
about as long as the coast of much of
the coast of norway for example
actually find intact ecosystems you can
fly at reasonably low levels and see
gigantic sunfish floating on their side
you know the way a thousand pounds or
more you can see whales you can see if
you're in a boat where the seabirds go
and then there's important
fisheries activities in that as well
there's a wonderful atlas of it if you
want to look at it online and you can
download that but
um there's all sorts of other activities
this is drawn from that atlas just
showing who's got
oil and gas exploratory wells and
tenures in the area
you know all sorts of people have staked
that territory there's another one that
shows
all sorts of different fisheries
interests well interspersed with those i
don't know if i've got the no i don't
i took it out
for time reasons
if i if i could show you where the
corals are
and where there's the thing called glass
sponges which we thought were uh
creatures that had gone extinct they
were studied as fossils in germany and
that was where they found them around
the uh
areas i think that are fossilized now in
germany and suddenly about 15 years ago
somebody discovered that there was huge
beds of these things
around this area that primarily the area
is kind of a pale orange
so what are you going to do about it
these were areas that were just
beginning to be used heavily by trawlers
the trawlers were starting to plow right
through these ancient beds because these
some of these are thousands of years old
and and
a stop was put to it um and now they're
all plotted we know where they are
there's exclusion zones for the corals
for the uh fisheries and the same
around up till about 2000 there was an
official almost denial that there was
these soft corals that were found on the
east coast and the fishermen had been
complaining about particularly
longliners that that the trawlers were
going through and bringing up these
things and i went to a fisher
fishery association museum in southwest
nova scotia
and they had all these big corals and if
you went on the west coast to
to some of the
nut commercial but sports fishing shops
and boat
places they'd have them on the wall same
thing on the west coast well officially
they didn't exist
and finally they did exist and now
there's all sorts of exclusionaries for
the red corals as well so progress but
it's slow and it's painful the northern
gateway i'm not going to even touch
tonight if you want to ask me questions
about it but but this is the prime
example now of why we need something
like pincima to generate the kind of
data that would be helpful to know how
much
what is the actual risk unfortunately
for whatever reason the government has
decided to more or less not totally but
more or less
gut the cooperation that had been
established through consema and and that
mechanism seems to be lost now
another one in the north is the beaufort
c partnership
which is a complicated thing and you can
see the vision of it is basically
ecosystem health and supporting
sustainable communities and economies
for future generations as well as the
present the problem with the beaufort c
partnership is uh there's a lot of
things that relate to
land claims and and
northern
local peoples up there
that have made it very difficult and i'm
not blaming them but it's just there's a
lot of obstacles in the way still to
make this move as fast as it should
another one where
another mechanism is in place now or
starting to get in places lancaster
sound lancaster sound there was one of
the first places where there were ceus
planning in canada and at that time that
was in the 1980s people were kind of
looking at as a bit of a curiosity now
this is a
very important part of the northwest
passage that will become one of the
areas used for shipping eventually
there's a large part of that as now
proposed as a national marine
conservation area
and and this will be very interesting to
see what this will actually mean in
reality now i want to point out the
the national marine conservation area
because we actually have legislation
saying that all the representative areas
in canada there's 26 or 27 of them
something like that each of those kinds
of habitats should have representative
areas where you could actually
pinpoint
and say aha this is this area is
protected within that and it will tell
us about the area it could be of use for
fisheries management and so forth
helping to replenish stocks
we're far from there
just to highlight again what
jordan was saying
look at the small percentage of
protected areas in the oceans in canada
compared to the land areas and most
people would say in the land areas it's
not enough
so
i don't look at the detail of this but
this shows all these different types of
areas you know you can look at hudson
bay for example or
the north and south part of
the
west coast pacific coast there's a lot
of areas but particularly in the arctic
we we need a lot more effort and one of
the things that cpaws which has been a
prime
contributor to this
they have a whole list of things that
they feel are urgent priorities for
marine protected areas and they're not
all being acted on at this point in time
so we do have a document and talk talk
talk talk is very cheap called the
national network of mpas do we have a
national network of mpas in canada
uh well here's one point of view from a
person who i respect a lot through the
pew foundation daniel polley from the
ubc fisheries center who's one of the
people that really understands the
oceans and fisheries very well in canada
and around the world
and he's been running something
a database called mpa global looking at
marine protected areas all around the
world
and if you go and look at the canadian
entry
there's 574 of them including provincial
coastal parks and ecological reserves
and so forth i can go out in my kayak
and go right around the ecological
reserves uh two kilometers offshore from
where i live
for birds for example marine parks in
british columbia there's dozens of them
but they're mainly for they've been
chosen not for their ecological value
although sometimes there is ecological
value but it's nice safe shelters for
boats that go up and down the coast you
know small pleasure boats or big
pleasure boats so
this is kind of overstates the case but
it's not daniel pauley's fault this is
following certain criteria
we're starting to see this now emerge
as networks within the regions so for
example
there's whale sanctuaries coral
sanctuaries
and a place called the gully where a lot
of the really interesting whales that
are offshore from nova scotia collect
now
and then there's a lot of actually
land-based ones which are primarily for
birds and protection of wetlands
the problem with this is can you really
call it a network what are the criteria
what how will it relate how will all of
this relate
that i've got on this diagram how will
it relate to sustainable fisheries
management because that's the kind of
question that we should be asking i
don't think we're asking that question
very well in canada now but i would urge
finn
to be thinking about that when you're
thinking about
sustainability of seafood and so forth
how does it relate back to the other
things in the ocean ecosystem and how
can we use those tools better
pinsema
this diagram
shows the
all these different
places that i mentioned the corals and
other areas that deserve some sort of
protection of one sort or another from
here and now
management issues things like the
trawlers and and other activities oil
and gas in some cases now
here is the makings of at least a west
coast northwest coast
network
here's what i'd like to see
if you look at
pinsieme and i've taken it out to the
200 mile zone because i feel we should
be going out to the 200 miles on this
but if you had
i call it bowie to brooks the brooks
peninsula is a really i should put a
picture of it and it's so interesting to
see it from the air
it's it's a finger of land that goes out
to the sea
an interesting place because
during the second world war when we were
patrolling all along the coast for uh
ships coming across from asia
a lot of ship a lot of airplanes were
lost in the bowie uh in the uh brooks
peninsula
because
right at that point there's a change in
the currents and you get all so there's
a north and the south current coming and
they change seasonally
and right at that point you can get i've
talked to a pilot about this when i was
flying over it with him and he was
saying that he had actually seen what
looked like niagara falls coming up
because the currents are clashing you
get this water coming up rising out of
the ocean and and he said it was just
like
this wall of water coming up and then
crashing down the other side in the
atmosphere
so these are the things that only pilots
see i guess but he said an exceedingly
dangerous area but it's it's
again a very important area separating
the north and the south and the kinds of
animal migrations whales and so forth
and seabirds
and then if you look at the top end
there's the bowie sea mount and and
there's seamounts these mountains that
rise up almost to the ocean top of the
ocean
but in the case of boise mount it comes
within 75 feet of the surface now i have
talked to people that have gone out
there and their sailboats big sailboats
and scuba dived on that seamount it's
filled with life it's absolutely filled
with life and and so
we have a whole series of these this is
the only one that currently gets any
protection whatsoever from fishing as
far as i can tell there's other things
in the scot islands and
rarity is very important
hooligan
estuaries another one of these strange
little fish
things that won't go into the sponge
reefs and so forth so this is not just a
big bland
body of light blue or anything like that
when you start looking at what's on the
bottom it needs protection
the sea otters coming back
and they're part of the ecosystem now
um
some first nations hate them because
they're taking oysters they're taking
all sorts of creatures that they want to
harvest uh
the coral reefs i've mentioned
way hanas
which is land
co-managed between parks canada
and now a marine conservation under area
under the marine conservation act and
the height of people
one of the most innovative systems of
co-management anywhere in the world
i mean this is fabulous and this is
going to mean a whole
different approach
towards fisheries management in the area
towards
how the height of people perceive
their responsibilities and how the
government of canada and the province of
canada actually
it's all done in a co-management basis
this is one of the most exciting things
that you can possibly imagine
and this is what the southern end
you can see down that yellow tip the
southern end
which happens to be
where the highest recorded winds were
ever
recorded it was off test oil rig there
in the 1970s i think it was
200 kilometers an hour or something like
that
so this is the kind of uh habitat that's
up there and you can see the animals
that are living there the sea lions
the beautiful areas
um
oops
sea mode
um
above that
rockfish
those fish
many of them are 70 years old and some
of my colleagues that want to protect
them and say would you eat your
grandparents
because they're delicious they're served
on many menus and
not very sustainably
harvested and in fact
before boisemont well it was still under
consideration that's just a
a plot of the depth contours and and
these currents that circulate around
on the voicemail
but
fishermen were being told to go out
there and fish
while they still could
so even in the
this is say seven or eight years ago
when when it was actively known that
boise was going to be
handled there was boats going out there
so now that problem is solved but
there's all these other problems along
the coast should you allow bullets to go
out to other seamounts
triangle island
most amazing place
the day i went out there the pilot said
you were lucky you get one to two days a
year when it looks like this and it's
not covered in rain and fog you can see
the little blip on the top of it
there was a lighthouse they put the
lighthouse up in the
in the cloud level so no the lighthouse
keepers could never see it the weather
was so bad there that lighthouse keepers
often would get no food for two or three
months at a time
sadly some of the lighthouse keepers
went crazy out there as well and and
there's only the base of the lighthouse
left a hurricane blew the lighthouse
itself away
and sadly also one of the leading
scientists that studied it's a great
place one of the great nesting areas for
certain
important seabirds
and
sadly one of the scientists fell off the
cliff and she died there's a wonderful
book though that's been written about
triangle island
with a lot of watercolors and so forth
by an artist that went out at a later
time it's it's it's a very interesting
spot now what do you think those things
are
uh innovation with ocean technology and
sovereignty issues such as signing onto
the law of the sea we've never ratified
the law of the sea
for example
i think it's time to revisit
and strengthen our commitment to the
oceans i think we've made a start with
the ocean's action plan but i think it's
got some good points and it's faltering
in some key areas and not enough
resources or
even attention is being given to it
ask when the last time this was reviewed
in parliament for example
the fisheries
as far as i can see the committee that
deals with fisheries
and oceans matters in the
current parliament is pretty much
dysfunctional certainly not dealing with
the kinds of questions that we're
talking about here tonight it will
probably receive the report of the
commission on environment and
sustainable development and mpas say
thank you we probably won't be needing
any serious discussion of this long-term
discussion of this thank you very much
for your hard work and that's what
things have degraded to it various times
now we need much more than that
so in the work of finn and with i hope
your other colleagues around the country
that you will join the voices of those
who do speak i think responsibly and
sensibly
about the and for the about and for the
oceans
but that you will take these kinds of
broader perspectives and keep those in
mind even as you focus very strongly on
the need for going after the individual
species and looking at the problems
related to
all of the fish that are out in the
ocean because
it's clear we're going to be eating more
varieties of them and
we're going to find some of them very
scarce still in the future
so thank you very much for your
attention this evening
so we've had your attention for a long
time tonight and uh
but
so
but you're welcome to ask some questions
if you'd like to do that i if you ask a
question then i'll repeat it because
then we can capture it on video and but
we'd be more than pleased to take
questions
if anyone has one then
uh yeah just to the general problem of
sustainability i don't know
if anyone's heard of donald wright's
idea of a progress drop
so like our ancestors
killing
two mammoths let's say over one is a
good idea that's progress but once they
could drive 200 off a cliff and kill an
entire herd and then like kill more
herds until they also our ancestors in
those areas would starve to death
because they killed all the mammoths
essentially um that would be progress
trapped quote unquote from donald trump
and i was wondering um
if you guys have any thoughts about
if that applies if that's like an over
simplistic generalization or
if it fits if is there anything we could
do about it
so the question is whether the idea of
progress trap is relevant to this issue
and the progress trap is
the expansion of technology to harvest
beyond sustainable limits i guess do you
want to take that sure sure
well it's part of a larger problem of
traps
and progress traps is certainly one and
we get caught in those traps because
something works
well for us for a time period and
certainly that was true in the fisheries
case and then when it doesn't work well
we're still
adhering to that approach
so one of the things and this is one of
the reasons why i bring out the
ecosystem work and so forth
we have to open our mind
to alternative possibilities and also
there's another little phrase that's
used called option foreclosure
you know for example if you lay out all
the different uses in the ocean
and everybody's scrambling for space in
the ocean you know the fishermen don't
want aquaculture because they can't park
their boats or their nets are in their
way whatever it happens to be the oil
people want one thing the aquaculturists
don't want the oil people etc so you've
got to have some rational case for
making choices but option foreclosure if
you do it well and zoning is one of the
ways to do that
allows for more to go on
but at a lower risk
and what we're doing now i think is
moving back towards a sectoral approach
where it happens right now
that the sector happens to be oil and
gas it could equally be some other
sector in the victim
could be deep ocean mining for example
or shallow ocean mining um and and so
we have to have a more rational basis
than just following whatever we think at
the moment is the best you know
and so that's that's really dealing with
the progress trap
um i think there's also
a kind and maybe it accompanies it but a
kind of a conceptual trap sometimes as
well you know we we adhere to ideas and
therefore won't open our minds up but
then something comes along
uh it could be some terrible accident
the classic cases the exxon valdez or
something like that and suddenly bang
you're in a whole new
environment of thinking
and you're not prepared for it you don't
have solutions you don't have haven't
thought your way through the kind of
knowledge basis you need
and and so that's another kind of trap
that we have to face because
that's why i say think about accidents
many of the changes in our society are
the result of accidents and something so
awful happens that we have to think of a
new way of doing things and so a lot of
what i think the scientific community is
dealing with in the oceans right now is
to say we've got to prepare ourselves
for a future that's very uncertain and
therefore we need to have a lot of
knowledge and we have to ask a lot of
what-ifs so that we are prepared to make
direction shifts as necessary in the
future whether they're from climate
change or some horrible accident or just
changing priorities in society
one of those priorities for sure
is that all those certification programs
are going to become the way we do
business
and those people who are not engaged in
that in the fisheries are going to learn
the hard way that's my prediction for
five to ten years
what would be the negative consequences
with zoning especially economic
consequences the loss of jobs or closing
in the histories
what would some of those be
the question is the negative potential
negative consequences of zoning
yeah it's a good question a really good
question
well to start with
it
is if you impose zoning
it's almost certainly going to have a
lot of negative consequences one of
which is people simply won't accept it
and therefore illegal activities will
take place
uh so the first thing about zoning is
it's got to be done on a consultative
and collegial and some including is the
wrong word collaborative way and
bringing stakeholders together that's
essential otherwise there's all sorts of
ways around zoning
the second thing about zoning is
if there are economic tradeoffs
one has to look at that
carefully because there may be ways to
avoid them and if you don't look at the
economics carefully then you can do
really dumb things with economic zoning
the third thing is
if you're going to make an assertion
like we have both made tonight that we
think mpas which is a type of zoning can
be helpful in the overall issue of
fisheries management
eventually maybe we can get away with
saying that for a number of years maybe
even decades eventually we've got to
show the results so there needs to be a
lot of monitoring and so forth as well
otherwise
it's your word against my word so to
speak
and so so those are some of the
consequences on the positive side if you
do things right with zoning you can
actually get added value you can have
well
give you an example there's a full page
ad in the paper uh in
in
british columbia i think it's probably
in a number of the papers by a group of
people engaged in marine tourism
on
the discovery
sound area which is up the coast a
little ways
and the point was in this case that they
feared a bunch of clear cutting that was
going to totally destroy or largely
destroy the potential for tourism
so
um you zone that you don't let that
happen
uh or do you just let it happen well
they've got the rights to
clear cutting um and the the people are
saying well we're going to lose our
livelihoods people aren't going to want
to come up and see clear cuts
so
those are things that if you do get
together there's probably a good
solution
and everybody gives at the end of the
day
but there's probably a solution it's the
same as that example between that i gave
of the whales going and avoiding the
ship collisions for years there was
resistance again you know there's going
to be ships crashing into each other and
all sorts of things or it won't work
work perfectly so so and that was a
zoning one so so look for the positive
side of it
and anticipate if there are negative
things can they be addressed
yeah
just from the point of view of an
organization like finn
i think uh i read that the ius
also engage in a lot of odious behaviors
that aren't necessarily related to what
you talked about tonight i.e you know
human trafficking yeah drugs now that
sort of thing and i'm just warning in
order to help
give the issue more political prominence
is there do you see linkages possible
or possibly between this issue and
others that people that other groups or
other people make you know sort of
consider to be sort of trigger ideas if
you understand the question yeah yeah so
so the question is given that there are
illegal phishing activities and that
those illegal activities spill
into other domains of illegality like
perhaps drug trafficking and human
trafficking are there ways of making
political capital out of those
connections
um and it's interesting that the iu and
i think that's relatively new that
people have been trying to make those
linkages even though we've known that
there are linkages
i i think the answer quick answer is yes
but it has to be done very carefully
and it has to be done on the it has to
be evidence-based
and it has to be done not just at a kind
of a global thinking level or won't lead
anywhere it has to be got down to
very serious things to give you one
example
in the 1980s
the
fisheries industry in the south of
thailand
really went into decline and it was fish
stocks they've been over fishing and all
they could catch were jellyfish and
squid
so and there's thousands of boats so
many of them turned into predatory
action against vietnamese refugees
coming out of vietnam
and it was a terrible situation really
awful
um well one of the things that happened
was that
thailand
which was very concerned and the rest of
the world was as well but thailand
decided that they would take on the
function of turning this past industry
into a processing industry for the
world's tuna and successfully managed to
build a whole new industrial basis
around taking frozen tuna from
everywhere in the world so if you look
at all your canned tuna if you happen to
eat tuna or
that you'll find most of it's been
canned in thailand ever since so it
created a new industry that at least
picked up some of the jobs
and got out of a lot of the illegal
other activities and and including a lot
of the illegal fisheries activities
because the ties were also going off
into indonesian waters and elsewhere and
just savaging
the fish stocks there and shrimp stocks
and so forth so there there can be
solutions to that
i think
the
on this iu thing it's a huge issue
fao has been very useful on it
and a lot of countries are now buying in
very uh in a very good way including
many developing nations i think we're
making progress on it but there's a long
way to go still and so anything that can
link it to the other illegal activities
some which are very odious to countries
that would be helpful
do you think that
aggressive activism like sea shepherd
can be positive or do you think that
that's counter productive
the question is whether aggressive
action like that of the sea shepherd can
be productive or whether overall that's
counterproductive
well i have a personal view on this my
personal view which is i think agreed
upon by at least some of my colleagues
not everybody is that we need a number
of different
it is a war that's being fought
and and
sea shepherd is
is fighting actively
on some fronts where others fear to go
but we need people who are on the fronts
whether it's greenpeace whether it's sea
shepherd whether it's people who are
milder in their actions but still for
example
in the case of sierra club now taking
harder stands they've decided which
might include some actions that are not
very nice but not on the level of
going out and ramming ships or whatever
the sea shepherd has been accused of um
i think that there's a whole a wide
spectrum
of things are needed some of which are
on that far end
and and i'm not
i don't want people to be injured in the
process but
they're making a point in a dramatic way
that that no others cannot make
um then there are the people that
that go out and there's lots of them
they go out and make movies they go out
and uh do active research
with money that's raised for their cause
and many of the ngos fall in this and so
they're not going that far but they're
still
they're still activists highly activists
and they're going out and they're
looking at the problems locally and
internationally and so forth and and
they're valuable
there's people like myself that have
chosen to work
closer to government but
i mean i i'd like to believe that i
understand some things about science and
i want to see that translated into
public policy
if i ever
went out and did something like seashell
right i certainly wouldn't be welcome in
some of the circles that i travel in
with with government people or whatever
so you make choices and then there are
scientists
that often
want to remain very close to their
science
whatever it happens to be
and would prefer to bring that
information freely and well out to the
public and so forth but not be the front
liners themselves
and and so and then there's others as
well
i also believe in the power of one you
know individuals like the school teacher
in the wales in nova scotia
that was just an ordinary school teacher
in a small rural school district
who
did something that was really very very
valuable at the time
and and we can find many other examples
i could tell you dozens of stories
there's people
um there's an organization
that deals with fisheries management on
a collective sort of basis on the west
coast of vancouver island
and they stick their necks out they they
work collectively between first nations
um and
with governments federal provincial is
supported from a variety of different
sorts and they manage a lot of species
that are not the big flashy salmon or so
forth but other things and they're
making progress in setting the basis for
a new form of fisheries management and
and it's tough let me tell you how tough
it is i i've because i've looked at this
organization quite closely
and and uh
so we need people that are activists in
different ways
we need people that are educators we
need researchers a whole range so i i do
think
i
must admit that i have a higher degree
of respect for paul watson than
many people might have i think he's he's
shown us he's shown a lot of light into
some very very dark corners
um okay so i kind of lead up on the same
question i'm interested in
how we can introduce this or how can i
extract something on the more like the
daily interaction that we have
you know like choosing a better
flavor
or you know
are there any maybe
way like because
with food on land like you know equality
is an important aspect so you can i
guess you could take an individual to a
farm
showing the process of what the choice
is yeah but how do you show something as
this i mean we don't have the same
connection with the fish
animals so is there another way of
educating uh more generally the public
why don't you take the first uh
you know you're a person who deals with
behavioral psychology sorts of things i
think
which this is all about psychology and
behaviors well the the question is and
consumerism what can you know what can
be done to link these issues to behavior
at a at a local level um
you know that's something that just
maybe if there's like a project that you
have or that everybody is circulating
that maybe we can appoint people oh yeah
even like because this is an
intellectual talk i would say and i
can't really
voice this information across
adequately so maybe if i can point
individuals well
the only the only real
effective means of changing individual
behavior that i think would actually
work is for people to write their mps
and members of the cabinet because
believe it or not politicians actually
pay attention to letters
and so
a lot of what we've talked about tonight
especially the marine protected areas
issue
isn't going to be moved forward unless
the politicians sense that there's
actual public demand like the
framework's already there right they've
signed the treaties and so on but the
way they're reading the population is
it's perfectly okay to ignore that and
the only way to change that as far as i
can tell is to indicate that it's
actually not okay to ignore it because
right now it is okay and and that's not
good our political system actually does
work it's much more permeable than
people really think because in some ways
it's left to its own devices you know
most people don't really participate in
the political system so it leaves it in
the hands of the very small minority who
do
but it's surprisingly permeable if
you're interested in permeating it and
so well that's that's my take at least
at the political level
that's one um let me give you four or
five things that i think are really
useful
one is
if you have the trust in them uh these
seafood guides are very helpful and so
you can use those in your own personal
life and if you go into a restaurant
uh ask them
has this and if you happen to enjoy fish
ask them tell me about this fish what is
a species where was it captured from
what is it certified fish that you're
serving
ask the chef to come out and talk to you
i've done that
and and and go in
if you use an ipad or a
an iphone and challenge them on some
things when they say they don't know
that there's no information and then i
did this once in a
very respectable restaurant in vancouver
and i warned them i said look i'm
bringing a group of people who are
leaders in this whole seafood process
they're going to have all sorts of
questions so i brought my ipad it was
brand new in those days did this come
out six months before and and we sat
down in half an hour
oh by the time the poor chefs were
sweating let me tell you but they
answered all the questions correctly we
got all the information and we got past
all these fancy names and so forth so
that's another way in dealing with the
food industry do it at a supermarket if
you're not getting good answers write to
the president of the company
and say you know i was in whatever chain
it happened to be local or national and
and i could not get any answer about
whether the crab that you're serving was
sustainably produced can you tell me
and if they can't
go after them and say please i really
want an honest answer but i'll bet
you'll get an answer
and and you'll make your decisions and a
third way is as you say go to the
politicians and keep going to the
politicians find out who the politicians
locally are they really have an interest
in the subject because there are little
clusters of people that don't get very
much support in both the senate and in
the house that really are interested and
they cross party lines in some of these
things as well
um and that's another way of doing it
but go to i think that on sustainable
development in general we have to go to
the cities
and i won't say anything about toronto
and this
political system right now how much this
would come up to the top but i know
certainly on the west coast and i think
a lot of places in the east coast it's
it's very central people will talk about
it to you and they are the places where
action is taking
taking on interesting approaches
uh the next one is
to figure out
and you can only do this yourself by
looking at different organizations
decide which organizations you're going
to support and support them in ways not
just maybe giving them some money from
time to time but ask how you can help
because
just to give you a couple examples world
wildlife fund uh canadian parks and
wilderness society both have excellent
excellent people that need support you
know not just
money but they need people behind them
in various ways and there's various
things that uh and i guess finally uh
if you have children will have children
or whatever
work with kids
kids genuinely
want to do things better they understand
kids
you know your cute animals well i was a
bit insulted about that fish that you
chose
but i thought it was kind of cute myself
but but but uh
the important point is that kids love
whales our little granddaughter who's
eight years old
she proudly announces oh i'm doing a
research project on pacific dolphin and
and by the time she finished that thing
she knew a lot about pacific dolphins
help people that way you know they get
at young people young people who really
want to because they they are upset by
these things they see it there's a lot
of stuff on television and so forth the
internet they they're getting done that
there's a problem and and they happen to
love these things they love dolphins
they love seals and they they said in
the other so many whales and and they
can't understand why these things are in
trouble or
the fish that they might eat are in
trouble so those are some concrete ways
that you can actually address this and
keep that list in mind as you move ahead
with finn as well because i think it's a
really important question
i'm talking and we all are talking that
maybe a bit abstractly here but
in each case you can bring these things
down to
to real life another one on the west
coast just to give you
uh now stop on this but
if you go to any school around victoria
greater victoria you'll see
salmon images
that the kids have individually made and
painted
and they're on the school fences
it's in front of them you know about
sustainable in some
communities uh spray painting around
sorry spray painting around uh gutters
and say you know this water leads to a
salmon stream
you know so
awareness
all right so
i think we've had your attention long
enough thank you very much for coming
that's much appreciated and uh
thanks to dr hanson thank you
you